he is not just their father in many ways
learning your falls is anti it Kimmy
because you folly is you being in
control and it's just you already know
how to try to do that it's just the fear
still taking you over okay so you should
not try to fall you should not have a
set way of falling that's not really
intended okay we say you tend me but
that's not a hidden folder role that
great fall those are naughty Kimmy
okay it's that stuff in between so all
right how do I understand the stuff
you've been doing now don't eat your
head let's just reduce it
okay and the second element which never
really comes out as you're doing your
forward roles or what have you is to
establish a relationship between your
center and the extremities of the body
you're supposed to but you don't need to
and so you don't
okay so let's work on some basic drills
will start with katate dori I'll be you
get the first thing is probably in the
largest proportion of our assigned
energy Prince
Kevon Massa his spinal displacement so
where he is I have to get energy that I
would be standing there making this
wrong
do you see this this this is going to
reduce your Aikido to joint manipulation
and we want energetic manipulation so I
always am pushing through the opponent
if I'm frightening is the same thing I
don't strike to here just like I don't
want to hear I always hold price media
for that is also consistent with a
solution aligners do you know what I
mean by that somebody is attacking you
they don't attack you like this even if
I was to grab him you would see the
aggression come in okay whether it's a
bribe here I'm gonna jump over here and
go like that oh it's always driving
through so
one of the things you can look at in two
prescribed energy grant and fulfilling
it is that by centers going forward
there's no way I can do spinal
displacement and keep my Center here or
going backwards you see that there's no
there's no way I can do that
I might be able to push them a little
but I won't be able to displace him from
where he's standing do you understand
that
okay therefore at no time in my Hemi in
fulfilling this prescribed energy print
should my butt be going backwards well
therefore at no time should my head be
going forward do you see that there's
just no way I can't make my head go
forward without my butt bone babbles you
see that by displace you see the
difference
I can push
so look for these two clues no no you're
doing it wrong third clue because we're
using to touch a dirty in this most of
the time his yet reconciliation because
I'm doing a young manifestation it's
going to create an hold there Sookie so
he doesn't he doesn't ten o'clock I'll
fall into that hole
do you see if I push from my Center my
head wasn't going forward and my butt
wasn't going here not reducing this to a
joint manipulation my mom will stay
completely on him he goes at no time
let's let me do the opposite look what's
happening you see there's a spaceship
any that'll happen maybe I do it I push
at first he starts to go and I put my
butt back and he'll peel out of my grid
so that's the third thing
no but back no head forward and no open
grip do you see that okay so let's just
start with this is going to be your
drill I am just going to displace him so
here and I move through him I'll do two
reps and that move three then he will do
title hair corresponds to that and I
will make sure there's no space on my
palm and I fall into that hole
from my initial attention watch the
difference tell me what you think is
different here I stepped into it I was
ahead that's wise you could see that I
stepped into it you see so I'm still
trying to be in control
that's choreography and it's a fear
response okay you don't like the whole
so you go I'm gonna step into space
no it's falling this space okay so fewer
XS final displacement then two reps
checking for these three things but head
grip and get your falling into the hole
so we came to the second half okay so
obviously there's a skill it is a skill
set so I probably can't get it up first
the problem is that it's not just a
physiological skill set it's a
psychological skill set okay so there's
a kind of physiological coordination
true but that coordination can totally
be inflation upon by a psychological
failure so in other words I I don't I
can't physically get the right correct
or the correct amount of flexion and and
relaxation in my posture and I'm afraid
and then that's gonna make you tense
everything okay or try to get ahead
so let's just look at the coordination
thing so when he pushes right what am i
what skills am i using here goodnight
grounding with that and my organization
if this is the coke Q skill to keep
things apart so a little bit and I
project it you understand
cook you projections separation there's
a grounding aspect to it
got it okay so here I am and what we're
doing what would what is this brings me
Bracey do you see if I push no
projection you see that this is just
fear is a fear model okay what did I
tell you not to do look at your head
it's going forward okay let's change
roles what am i doing Bracey
I'm not grounding okay so just as he
pushes here I'm ground out well
now i ground his resistance I'm
grounding his resistance do you see that
and so this is why from step to step
I I can keep walking
so he can try to you try to reground as
i displace you okay so he's grounding
and I'm going to walk do you see that
would you go like this okay and the
whole thumbs you will fall into it but
if you pay attention you will have
disconnect and then when it should the
technique turn on me
whoa now I have lost the relationship
necessary for a character do you see
that so I am NOT a person who goes
flying in and then gets taken off
balance let me let's watch that skill
again that just happened okay so if
you'll do time I think oh and then he'll
do another turn watch do you see me in
the bracing angle watch what happens to
my body go you see this huge state of
off-balance
let's do ski and he moves out of the way
okay
ski does that look like a good punch
dear that looks like that idiot right
Hebrews out of the way Hebrews out of
the way one key change angles so word
don't we have the right physiological
organization you're bracing then you do
fall in but you don't have a camera okay
here push room here no this is wrong
that takes you right into the bracing
and pay attention you just go well I'm
just gonna do it a little okay don't do
it at all
here we'll go to 0.5 drill here
okay point five okay so back to drill
one so I'm pushing from mirror the back
foot is grounding all of the charge
that's happening for me increasing
friction here back foot back foot not
front foot back foot right till it
passes so it's going into a young face
young face it can't go anymore and but
you'll see that the front foot can now
go into a young face see so watch my
knee angle okay front knee driving down
front knee now comes to the toes do you
see that well once once the front foot
does that that's where I have push
that's where I have the new grounding
foot you see that it's so I can walk
when you do the other one
you've pinned yourself you see and
that's why you fall okay here grab the
back foot give me some energy from the
back foot shift the front foot passes
into the young face and this foot is off
but I have to ground me and I'm just
walking
do not prioritize moving in prioritize
proper weight shifting whoa boom there
it is
okay drill one go okay so all that all
that is supposed to happen
onon in an instant that it's the same
thing when when when he pushes right all
this happens on it okay so that is why
you're really training the same things
on you get Nuggets time okay
but right now you guys are like this is
how you come in okay it's how you can
time you see to move your body moves
through you don't you're not hauling
he's doing something to your geometry
that creates Inquisition I'm not doing
it and I'm not violating sound fighting
kinesiology okay so let's try now I'm
practice and go back to the other drills
I'm moving through
[Music]
and I'm trying to do it right on contact
whoa that reads from its wrists I have
to feel his center then write up contact
he does his thing but I don't let go my
attention here's where the psychology
comes in is you're gonna go whoa you're
gonna pull out okay right on contact he
goes and I want this ball right into my
only a is to hold the courage so I can
hold the center periphery relationship
what we tend to see is this this
experiences life falling right on
contact us then we all stop and settle
without breaking that relationship right
on contact
okay so to war on contact displacements
boom and then to into the drill my
sparring tastes exactly the same okay
he's not leading me and I'm not
following him there's no following or
leading in item there's there is the
jiu-jitsu but if I want to go to the
next level
there's no swallowing or leaking you're
doing it wrong yeah that's why there's
no choreography okay so I have to stay
in my center relationships
my periphery head and feet usually and
ham to my Center and then you apply the
principle of concentric truth well
there's a periphery in the center of
relationship between he and I do you
understand his job is to maintain it and
if I maintain my relationship and he
maintains the center there's we don't
need following and leading to get that
so let's watch some of these things okay
he will do the time momentum do you see
me spinning around that's me not you
okay you can only do that because you
disconnected and remember like rushing
staff consults you disconnected from the
original intention so you disconnected
from the center periphery relationship
so you disconnected from that nugget you
can relationship okay
so as he goes here you'll see that I
realize I totally relaxed
let's unwind how this happens look at my
relationship to my arm you see this it's
in a different place
you see this move out of the way please
you see so what did I do
I broke relationship here
by center and my periphery my lives are
in the relationship always in the
relationship this is not it boom-boom
so if he pushes down he's gonna feel the
weight he's got to lift that leg do you
see when I'm over here like this he goes
down my arm will move you get here's it
your fourth rule if he's stopped moving
I should stop moving not I'm gonna try
to stop moving
I just wouldn't move he's not moving me
why would I move so when his relation is
movement stops cool you see it stops
don't break this relationship my
shoulder is still engaged between my
head and my feet my arm is not loose
okay he feels my weight okay okay so
well why do you think we're
disconnecting there's a couple reasons
one is again the fear the fear causes us
to disconnect because the energy that
we're working with requires
consciousness and presidents and the
entire system my organization my
relationship to him my relationship to
the prescribed energy print all all of
that you can kind of think of it as a
matter of the station of creation who is
sure to go and now you lose Costas pull
this part falls out the whole thing
falls apart okay so it could be fear I
go in here that fallen is on whoa whoa
you're trying to get the
your body do you understand well
spiritually guess what you're practicing
over and over cowardice cowardice this
is not the way of the lawyer so he's not
hurting me
is he okay so I just practice it's it's
a it is a courage drill because of the
relationship between fear and
unconsciousness don't diminish it it is
exactly that so I'm pushing ego and I
maintain consciousness so I maintain
organization got it
so it could be fear I go you're low low
low and I start to take off pressure but
again if you pay attention you will
always have that gap there so let's
amplify the gap again if I have certain
skill so here here I have my keys you
can see I'm still doing the same thing
without gripping him just from here boom
through if I don't have that skill guess
what I'm not doing this room okay
but this is how everything works so as
he goes I can keep the relationship
without losing the palm
okay let's try that okay the second
reason you might be doing that is just
you black discipline so you stop early
so I go I'm here
I still hold in a relationship I go like
I just know Zhongshan on both sides so
you go back to Griffin if you want he
goes maintain it the rule should be that
he's dangerous and armed dangerous and
dangerous things did not turn off their
guards okay so he comes in he knows I'm
ready to kick his frickin ass if he lets
go that harm control he takes his Center
out of that man he's gonna free me and I
know that to you he's not rested no
initiate that release and we agree every
pretty face
you almost always see these combinations
go you get it it's not dangerous
a control I have to attack the center
I'm not coming in to go around this
Center you see every drill it does not
move get filled out but it okay let's go
oh you're supposed to push me to finally
take the weight down this is what this
is what I've seen come back please
here's our salute disconnect
reconnection
[Music]
get your weight in there feel the arm
that's it okay late
it's about this stay connected you know
you don't try to catch up to me my
weight is on something there's no off
drop your arm oh just this same
relationship touch you see touch on it
stays up your head
there's no that's not here
that's behind so the drill boom
tiny little drop the slap slap slap make
La Crescenta head and feet head and feet
so I don't need choreography
do you understand but you really do you
see but if you have this sincere attack
my body was in there she goes try so to
do this fire the architecture we tend to
puke in a tilt let's tilt
okay because that's the most efficient
way of taking someone out you begin to
tilt and then you have a new line of
attack that goes an X pattern over the
tilting angle okay
so as I'm pushing he goes he drops I
move okay watch this
that's not accepted to my feet
it's me disengaging go back to grill one
five but went backwards so cool is with
my head you see the tilt when he drops
his hand if my head goes down my foot
comes up that's maintaining center if I
go here he goes this is breaking center
but going back you'll have the space on
the grip
dinky have to use Center to make me move
so we'll ask Kim I'll do the first one
go go which one's easier that one's
easier it's not half less fast than then
I do this second one you see I'm also if
the technique continues and I go here
and he turns guess what
just as he tilted my Center he can do
that because my centers in my hand as he
turns he's just going to move a lot
what's that Louisiana I'm Corinne I'm
playground do you see that all I'm doing
is Center hands we go you move again
which one's easier this one it's not
anything
[Music]
there's no Leedy and no following you
want to get off the spectrum of is you
can't are making the technique happen or
I as you can don't do the technique that
is still leading and following that's
not I okay all I do is what I've said to
do so when he goes around this foot is
now pulled out the technique you see how
there's that and I'm going back I'm
doing that tilting room do you see that
if he if he my hands of my Center and he
moves by that he's gonna move me if I
pull my Center out it's done I get this
and you're retaining starts to look like
each one of those steps is resistance
your finest
so we do this row you'll turn kilt off
this yeah sure okay let's go maybe you
don't know what's the difference
but someone speak like a leader
to do what yes how would you decide that
you're stopping yourself
this to me is staccato is that what you
saw
I'm sorry modulo I'm trying to solve
myself yeah there's a ball that's
actually when I run I picked around this
way you see enough like whoa look I can
do it
do you see what puts my Center by hand a
particular external postural geometry no
century by him is it only when I'm
pushing hair no he pushes me Center in
one hand you see so as he goes around
whoa
I'm not maintaining all these concentric
circles okay
it should just be normal
[Music]
each one of those stops is preceded by
addition to that which now he pulls you
you see
tell me where you spot a conscience
choreography of my body and you should
feel that Marshall you get it
think I just connected his hand so I'll
show you're gonna keep yours never in
there
keep it in there keep it in there you
mean it because this time we'll come
back the kitchen okay
this sound will come back when you take
that step
I mean do you want to here's what's
happened I push and then I it's no
different than that I pushed and now we
go under the day when I go under the
technique I take my Center out of my ha
you see that because he's his body right
here if he's doing the tutor drill
Jeter's up you see so he feels bye wait
there when I go under watch what you're
just feeling you see comes off so you
would feel that and you just come right
into my head
oh so we want to train this way because
you're not recoding conscious to the in
space
do you understand that so you're not
becoming conscious to where the
techniques begin and end as well as all
the other things we mentioned so I told
you was dangerous got it
so as much as he's painting me what do
you think I'm doing I'm pinning him ok
so he goes bull but I'm occupying that
arm if that arm goes dead goes dead then
I can come in I'm checking him out
now you turn over for his center is in
that path we see something whoa Center
stays in that house whoa I'm always
writing here right getting him I let go
talk to you to repeat backwards what do
you think you're gonna do you're gonna
disengage do you wanna go into something
else but okay let's go remember if
Henry's not following a certain way and
I I started this by saying you shouldn't
follow the same way every time
okay I gave you another clue when the
head goes down foot must come up by the
way you brakes him so as he goes when I
go like this okay he's bringing me in
but he's not bringing me forward let's
say let's say I'm here and he walks that
way he's gonna move I sit here he hid so
my foot is frightened by what it comes
out if I eat if he's pulling my
centreboard is he's going all that way I
can feel my grip open you go it's here
he starts to bring me around my head's
going by
into my foot do you see it's not here
this is broken Santa turn this like this
is broken Center 7 you break sector for
the sole reason that you want to do your
back rainfall that's not candy I don't
know how you're going to fall other day
you will reconcile with that watch when
I do that my experiment okay let's go